[Music]
i never went into my brother's room
after that winter
i was six or almost seven to be more
precise cory was fifteen sullen and
cocky by turns
because of the difference in our ages he
seemed almost like a representative of
an exotic species living in my own home
a person who had unbelievably known my
parents my parents
for a full eight years longer than i had
we lived in an older part of town and
there were kids of all ages on our
street
i usually played with the miller girls
from around the corner or sometimes with
simon
the bookish little boy next door corey
of course hung out with a group of guys
his own age
riding bicycles playing video games
lighting stolen firecrackers and
harassing the neighborhood girls
no matter what their ages or
predilections though all the local kids
knew about old heartworms
there was a cemetery with the idyllic
name of fisher's hills just two blocks
from our house
it was a pretty standard cemetery small
but well-kept with a neat green lawn
punctuated by clean evenly spaced stones
most of the stones had fresh flowers put
on them once a week
but behind the main part of fisher's
hills chaos and disrepair
reigned here graves were broken or
kicked over
grass and weeds were allowed to
proliferate and grow into the cracks in
the stones
no fresh flowers were ever in evidence
just some mummified petals from bouquets
placed by mourners who were probably now
long dead themselves
corey told me once in one of his rare
truthful moods that the back of the
cemetery was a dumping ground for people
who couldn't afford a decent
burial or who were unidentified i had
lain awake all that night after he told
me
thinking how horrible it must be to die
without anyone knowing who you were
the story of old heartworms was another
one i originally heard from corey
though i heard other versions from some
of the kids my own age
apparently he was a homeless man who had
dropped dead in the gutter of the town's
main street
one day a long time ago maybe even when
my parents were still children
there had been a city-wide search for
his next of kin but no one had come
forward to claim him
a few days later he was duly interred in
the back of fisher's hills
with no headstone but then according to
the legend
the worms that had started their dirty
work on the old man got into his heart
and inadvertently got it going again
heartworms woke up in a foul mood
and dug his way out of his pauper's
grave bent on revenge on a city that had
treated him with such disrespect
it was said that people who passed
heartworm's grave late at night
or said his name three times aloud would
soon hear his rotting footsteps behind
them
and the stench of his decaying breath on
their necks a few seconds later he would
rear up and tear out your heart
right through your chest and eat it
while you died
depending on who was telling the story
it could be more or less graphic
when corey told it he'd turned off the
lights in my bedroom and held a
flashlight under his chin
going into great detail about the worms
eating at old heartworms's face
chewing up the flesh squirming in the
poor man's eye socket
i had screamed and begged him to stop
but i hadn't wanted him to
not really the fear was too delicious
corey had told me about heartworms when
i was only four years old and i didn't
hear too much more about the old man
until early that winter
it happened that shortly after
thanksgiving that year the year i was
almost seven
there was a succession of three murders
unheard of in a small close-knit town
like ours
there was no apparent motive for the
crimes and the victims were not
connected in any way one was a drifter
one was a young schoolteacher and one
was a priest all three were terribly
mangled
cut to ribbons with unbelievable fury
the stories about heartworms began
circulating again after the third body
was found right near the cemetery
all bloody flayed limbs scattered among
the weeds
but the police dismissed the rumors as
silly explaining that we had a serial
killer in our midst
they even claimed they had a couple of
suspects which they were investigating
with all the resources at their disposal
it also happened that one of corey's
classes at school was planning a local
history pageant
to be given the day before school let
out for christmas break
each student had to pick a local
historical figure and give a spoken
report
dressed as the person he was reporting
on and of course the subject of every
report had to be submitted ahead of time
to the teacher for approval
corey told his teacher that he was doing
the report on uriah hastings a famous
civil war general from the area
but really he was planning to do a
report on heartworms
i'm not sure if anyone else knew of his
plans but me and the only reason i knew
was because i went into his room one day
to look for one of my missing toys
and saw the costume he was making
normally he kept it under his bed so
that our mother wouldn't see it but he
had just run to the kitchen for a coke
and so it left it in the middle of the
floor
it was hideous i could see that already
corey wasn't the artistic type but he
had always been good with his hands
to this day i don't know exactly what he
made the costume out of but it was
eerily effective
the body was really nothing more than
rags and corn syrup blood
with ribs artfully drawn in here and
there with paint and markers
he'd even glued a few rubber worms on
there and rubbed the whole thing
with dirt from the backyard the face
though was what still haunts me
all these years later it looked alive
even with its empty staring eye sockets
and flat deflated shape
corey had taken handfuls of the rubber
worms and glued them into the semblance
of a nose and mouth
then painted the whole thing black with
accents of blood red
punctuated by sprinkles of red glitter i
remember finding a piece of red glitter
on the bottom of my bare foot many years
after that winter
and i screamed and screamed until my
mother came running
at which point i fell into her arms in a
dead faint
i still can't stand the sight of red
glitter nowadays when i wake up in the
middle of the night i always think of
the empty hallways of our old house
and think of glitter winking at me from
the cracks in the floorboards
corey came from downstairs and saw me
looking into his room and he yelled at
me and punched my arm hard
then he pushed me out into the hall and
slammed the door in my face
but at that point i didn't care i didn't
want to see old heartworms lying there
on the floor anymore
i didn't even like the thought of it in
there it's wormy countenance just
waiting for cory to climb inside and
animate it
the thought of corey's eyes behind that
face blinking out at the world made my
stomach clench
and i ran for my own room throwing
myself under the covers
all through the next month the
heartworms costume was never far from my
mind
ordinarily i would have been excited
about the impending holiday and kept
myself busy daydreaming about the two
weeks of vacation from school
and the present santa would inevitably
bring but that year i was subdued
fearful my mother kept asking if i was
sick and i would deny it
but her constantly knitted eyebrows let
me know that i wasn't convincing her
there was also another murder in the
interval between thanksgiving and
christmas
this time the victim was a bank clerk a
man covered with blood and carrying a
black bag full of knives and scalpels
was apprehended leaving the victim's
house this man was later determined to
be the serial killer the police had
sought
he had no reason for his crimes but was
simply a psychotic madman picking off
people at random
which happens more often than most of us
probably like to think
once he was in custody the whole town
seemed to breathe a collective sigh of
relief
a few days later though he escaped from
the police station
they never did find him again on the day
before christmas vacation
corey stuffed his heartworms costume
into a gym bag and climbed onto his
bicycle
i watched him as he rode off wondering
if he was going to get into trouble for
giving his report
i imagined his teacher wouldn't have
much of a sense of humor about the whole
thing
especially considering the whole serial
killer business
did i have a premonition that day as
corey cycled off towards school
i've asked myself that question many
times in the ensuing years and i still
don't have a satisfactory answer
even if i had known what could i have
done i was only a seven year old girl
then who knew nothing of the world
so i watched him go and then i turned
and walked in the opposite direction
toward my own school
corey never came home that day i still
remember the street growing darker
outside
and the sound of my mother's frantic
voice as she called everyone she knew in
the neighborhood that had a boy cory's
age
have you seen my son she asked all of
them and none of them had
his teacher said he'd been in school
that day he had given his report and
even though his history teacher was
angry she hadn't scolded him too harshly
the other kids had thought his costume
was hilarious and his history was his
last class of the day
corey had left the costume on as he left
school pushing his bike toward home
that was the last time anyone had seen
him dressed as a legendary homeless
killer
pushing a huffy 10 speed down the
sidewalk
mother didn't sleep that night i don't
think anyone in the neighborhood did
there were flashlights and dogs men
shouting in the streets well into the
small hours
i wrapped a blanket around myself and
curled up on the couch watching tv but
not
seeing it instead seeing corey's eyes
blinking behind a mask of worms and red
glitter
i knew when they had found the body
because my father carried me up to my
bedroom and tucked me under the covers
he left the lights on but closed the
door firmly behind him
his face had been very pale i strained
to hear what he and mother were saying
downstairs
but all i could hear was more shouting
from outside and then crying and wailing
and a dog howling somewhere not far away
they didn't tell me exactly what had
happened of course but i found out much
later
corey's body was found in fishers hills
near the back where all the weeds grew
wild
he was still in his heartworms costume i
was told that the head of the costume
had been torn from the body
and that corey's head was still staring
out from behind the mask
his chest was nothing but a mass of
blood and exposed ribs beneath the rags
red glitter was ground into the dirt
around the body as though by a heavy
boot
i'm 20 years older now and i live far
away from that old house where i grew up
i lived there for another 11 years after
that winter and like i said i never went
into cory's room in all that time
his killer was never caught and even
though the police made a great show of
trying to solve the case
and pinned the murder on the escaped
serial killer deep down i think everyone
in town knew what had happened
in a way i can't blame old heartworms
for what happened to my brother
i suppose it's never wise to mock the
dead especially those whose existence
has been so plagued with sorrow
and even now that i'm miles away i still
don't say his name out loud
[Music]
bye
[Applause]
[Applause]
i picked up the girl on a different
street than usual i figured that since
she was going to be my last one i'd
alter the routine some have a sort of
celebration
i didn't really look at her as she got
in the car just a quick glance
enough to see their face seemed crooked
as though her jaw had been broken at
some point and hadn't healed properly
she was also a little on the hefty side
but that was okay
i told her that i lived way out in the
woods but that i'd pay her extra if
she'd come out there with me
i put on my most disarming grin she just
said that's fine
not concerned at all she had sized me up
when she first got in beside me i had
noticed her doing it
evidently she didn't think i posed any
threat that was good
after speaking she stared straight ahead
out the windshield her painted lips
hanging slightly open
i handed her some folded bills and then
i pulled away from the curb
she didn't say much on the long drive
just gave me one word answers to my
innocuous questions
i didn't ask her name and i didn't tell
her mine when i had driven off the main
highway and the trees closed in around
the narrow two lanes
i asked her if she minded doing you know
kinky stuff
i glanced at her again and in the green
glow of the instrument panel i thought i
saw the ghost of a smile
i'll do what you pay for she said i
decided i liked this girl very much
the tires crunched on the dirt road as i
stopped the car in front of the house
i had left the porch light burning but
its yellow glow seemed insignificant
a paltry flame in the midst of a vast
black wilderness
i could hear the deafening chirp of the
crickets even before the car door was
open
it's pretty dark out here said the girl
i was alert for any quaver in her voice
any sign of nervousness but there was
none
she was just making conversation i'll
put all the lights on when we get inside
i patted her knee brotherly then i got
out of the car
i heard her following me her high heels
thumping up the porch steps
i flipped on all the lights as soon as i
crossed the threshold just like i said i
would
the house looked warm and cozy curtains
closed against the night
wooden floors shining softly nice place
said the girl
thanks i shrugged off my denim jacket
and draped it over the back of the sofa
can i get you some water or juice or
something sorry i don't have anything
stronger i'm not much of a drinker
thanks i'm fine then have a seat
i watched her as she settled into the
easy chair next to the fireplace
she was looking around taking in the
rustic hominess she seemed completely at
ease
i'll be right with you i said she nodded
absently
staring down at the navajo rug under her
feet
i pushed through the door to the kitchen
my skin already feeling hot
i opened the drawer next to the
refrigerator and took out all the
supplies
the small blade a roll of gauze a few
squares a paper towel
a clean mason jar when i went back into
the living room carrying them i saw her
gaze slide from my hands to my face to
my hands again
her eyes widened just a touch and one
eyebrow rose
questioning but otherwise she was as
relaxed as before
she's a tough one i thought and started
to sweat through my clothes
some of the girls started to protest at
this point some of the more skittish
ones would have been already bolting for
the door
i held up my hands showing her the
things familiarizing her with them
i won't hurt you i said is it okay
she looked almost amused what are you
gonna do
i knew my cheeks were burning red and i
knew she thought i was blushing
i'm sort of into bloodletting i knelt
down on the floor in front of her chair
she nodded slowly i've met a couple like
you
you
won't take much will you no no not much
i don't need much
i was getting excited my voice was
starting to shake and i made myself calm
down
i've even got some bandage c for
afterwards i held up the roll of gauze
she'd been wearing a long sleeve top
sheer but not transparent just teasing
she pulled it over her head and tossed
it onto the floor
she didn't have a bra and underneath are
you going to [ __ ] me then she asked
no i just need your blood then i can do
it myself
okay the girl was probably no more than
19 but she acted older
wiser like she was humoring me in a
childish whim
i saw the attitude a lot in the girls i
brought home but mostly i could tell it
was all
put on with this girl i couldn't tell
where are you gonna take it from she
asked i'll make a small cut on your arm
i won't hit any major veins or anything
don't worry i do this a lot
i guess so she laid her arm out flat
underside up just like she was giving
blood at the doctor's office
do i get a tennis ball to squeeze her
eyes were sparkling
i laughed it sounded a bit high giggly
but otherwise normal
you can squeeze the gauze roll if you
really want to
she took it from me and curled her
fingers around it her nails were painted
pink but chipped on the edges
well let's go drak she really was
something else
most of the other girls were scared or
blase or sullen or a combination of the
three
okay i said i had the little knife in
one hand nice and sterile
and in the other i held the mason jar
that i positioned under her arm to catch
the spill
are you gonna let me watch you drink it
she asked
i had the feeling she was starting to
enjoy herself
it's not for me to drink i need it for
something else
i'll have to wait and see then huh yep
i smiled at her making it all a joke a
conspiracy between the two of us
me the eccentric middle-aged guy with
his cabin out in the woods
she the screwed by life hooker with the
dry wit and the girlish pink fingernails
and the crooked jaw i drew the blade
across her flesh
quick and decisive it hurt less that way
or so some of the girls had told me
still this girl sucked in her breath
through clenched teeth obviously in pain
but she didn't cry out
a line of red welled up immediately and
began to drip
she watched fascinated as i held the jar
there collecting her vital fluids
i never took much it wasn't necessary
when there was about a quarter of a
crimson inch in the bottom of the jar i
scraped the lip of it across her arm
sopping up the leftovers then blotted at
the wound with some of the paper towels
here pressed that down i told her and
then i unrolled a length of gauze and
wrapped it tight around her arm
bloody paper towels and all it's not
very deep i said
the bleeding will stop soon she bent her
arm up at the elbow holding the gauze in
place and watching me as i set the jar
down on the floor between my knees
there was some blood clumped around the
lip and a few gaudy streaks running down
the inside of the glass
but that didn't matter i unbuckled my
belt and then undid my jeans
do i have to do anything else she asked
she wasn't smiling anymore but she
didn't look upset
just curious no just relax
keep holding your arm my erection was
raging by this time
pushing at my underwear like a beast in
a cage i freed it and even though it was
warm in the cabin i felt a cold breath
on the tender skin
i hardly needed to touch myself at all
it all came flowing out of me
and i fumbled with the jar managing to
get all of it in there
white over red strawberries and cream
elixir meets elixir
the girl's eyes were like probing lasers
on the top of my head
i knew she was staring even though i
wasn't looking at her
i was panting my hands still full of my
wilting organ
i shook it briefly over the jar making
sure the last few pearly drops found
their mark among the girls proteins
then i wiped myself clean with the last
paper towel and zipped back
up it had taken less than 30 seconds
as i screwed the lid on the jar and held
it up to the light mesmerized by the
mingling fluids
i caught the expression on her face she
didn't look scared but the corners of
her mouth were turned down
in mild distaste i expected her to say
something
come up with some witty comment but she
didn't i was disappointed
i thought we were establishing something
of a rapport
i peered closer into the jar i knew she
couldn't see them but i could
millions of them moving feeding on the
warm woman blood beneath
i could see a tiny body inside each cell
perfectly formed and whole
waiting to feed and grow getting a
little stronger and a little bigger
every day
the girl did speak then hey mister if
you're done i wouldn't mind getting back
out to my spot before it gets much later
i knew she was disgusted by me now and
trying not to show it
she had that much class at least in a
minute i said
i'm just checking to see if your blood
is sufficient sufficient for
what she was interested despite herself
for them to feed on who the homunculi
the homo what she had reached down and
retrieved her shirt and was carefully
putting it back on over the gauze
the miniature men inside the cells she
leaned forward trying to see into the
mixture in the jar
you're kidding you mean inside the sperm
cells
yes she threw back her head then and
laughed
really laughed the sound rumbling up
from some place deep in her belly and
painting the walls with mirth
you really think that there's a little
man inside each of your sperm cells
there is okay she rolled her eyes
then she got to her feet pulling the
wrinkles out of her blouse with her
unbandaged arm
you seriously need some counseling or
some sex education
no offense from where i sat she looked
like a giantess
none taken good she walked over to the
doors if she lived here and was just
going out for a pack of smokes
are you gonna take me back now i stared
into my jar
mentally saying hello to each and every
one of my new creations
they seem to be enjoying the blood
feasting on it with great gusto
i tried to estimate how many there were
in there a few million surely
but it was hard to count them when they
kept moving around and to be honest they
all looked pretty much alike
but there had to be enough now i glanced
up at her
why don't you wait out in the car it's
unlocked i'll just put this away and
then i'll be right out
sure thing she shook her head at me
again like a mother grappling with the
strange fantasies of a child
you know i've met a lot of weirdos in my
time but i must say that you take the
cake
was there something like admiration in
her voice
thanks i didn't know quite how else to
respond
go on i'll catch up take your time
in less than a second she had gone out
into the night shutting the door quietly
behind her
i heard her heels again clicking on the
boards of the porch
then i heard another noise she was a
tough one alright
she screamed like the dickens and it
took a long time for those screams to
weaken and finally whimper out to
silence
i almost felt bad about it she seemed
like a nice enough girl
kinda spunky which i like but what else
could i do
the fully grown ones have to be fed just
like the baby ones do
and they develop a taste for women's
blood while they're still in the jar
it's pretty much all they'll eat i'm not
sure how many there are
of the big ones i mean they live out in
the woods all around
i don't have enough room for them in my
house of course at night if you look
very hard into the trees you can see
them
the girl must have seen them as soon as
she walked down the porch steps toward
the car
they get antsy when they know there's
fresh meat in the place
she must have seen a whole wall of them
out there coming toward her
a bit stunted and misshapen but
otherwise bearing a more than passing
resemblance to me i wonder how she felt
about that
i took the jar into the kitchen and
placed it on the windowsill they always
like to be able to see the sunrise
i'm not sure how many are in the jar and
i'm not sure how many are in the woods
like i said
but i know there are at least a few
million of them probably closer to
several million
a bigger number than any army on earth i
wasn't certain before
but i know now that i have enough
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
are you sure you're ready for this the
doorbell rang
too late now isn't it debra laughed
ruefully
don't worry i'm fine kevin answered the
door
anna stood there dark hair pulled into a
bun bottle of wine in hand
sorry i just remembered she probably
can't drink this
debra standing behind her husband smiled
and took the bottle
a small glass won't hurt me or the
little resident
she put her hand on her midsection
charlotte arrived next
then jeremy once everyone was inside
kevin disappeared into the kitchen
debra followed him but he shooed her out
go on sit with the guests
everything's under control 15 minutes
later the food was on the table and wine
had been poured into everyone's glass
except for deborah's
she wanted to save hers for afterwards
thanks for coming everyone it means a
lot to me
she looked around the table at each of
them in turn with her warmest glance
reserved for her husband
kevin squeezed her hand least we could
do honestly
said jeremy i can't even imagine the
[ __ ] storm you must be going through
well we can sort of imagine it anna
amended but it must be a hundred times
worse for you
as if on cue there was a sharp banging
on the windows and then the sound of
raucous fading laughter and epithets
everyone around the table was silent for
a few moments then there was an outburst
of uncomfortable chuckling
exhibit a ladies and gentlemen said
deborah you two get this all the time
charlotte was by far the youngest of the
group as her guileless anxiety and acne
scarred face attested
she turned to kevin doors locked right
yes it is
and yes it's been pretty constant but
it's nothing we haven't weathered before
jeremy tore off a chunk from his dinner
roll and buttered it thoughtfully
this case was so much bigger than any of
debra's others though maybe you should
think about going away for a while or
changing your phone numbers at least
it'll blow over soon enough it always
does debra patted jeremy's hand
thanks for your concern though jeremy
smirked no problem
later once kevin had cleared the dinner
dishes and brought out the coffee
charlotte said so how does this work now
that the trial is over
are you allowed to talk about it she'd
probably rather not
kevin gave his wife a side long glance
the point of the party was to try and
forget about all that for a while
debra waved a hand at him i don't mind
but there isn't much to tell
she wants to know if you think cooper
did it jeremy was on his third glass of
wine
and his pale blue eyes were shining it
wasn't my place to determine that
you were painfully ethical debra said
anna but i'm technically not a lawyer so
i can tell you that i absolutely think
he did it
debra raised her eyebrows and mock
surprise you're in the majority then
i think you thought so too just a
feeling i got
debra sat back in her chair and pondered
this kevin asked her if she wanted wine
and she said she did
so he got up to get it charlotte got up
also
excuse me folks i have to use the ladies
don't talk about anything interesting
until i get back
same goes for me except i need the gents
jeremy said
he got unsteadily to his feet top of the
stairs
kevin said as he went into the kitchen
when everyone was back at the table
deborah said
honestly i was kind of ambivalent about
cooper i'm not sure he's capable of the
brutality he was accused of
but i didn't like him personally he gave
me the creeps
i felt like he kept trying to push our
relationship in inappropriate directions
she frowned into her wine glass and then
laughed was that diplomatic enough for
you
you can't blame the guy deborah you are
by far the hottest and blondest of all
the defense attorneys in town
jeremy said i'm still sorry i [ __ ] all
that up
deborah's voice was gentle and a little
teasing let's not go there jeremy
no more wine for you jeremy ducked his
head and mumbled an apology
the clock struck 10 then 11 and still
the guests made no motions to leave
jeremy had sobered up but kept mostly
quiet as the others discussed topics
other than the cooper murder trial
deborah's pregnancy kevin's impossible
class load charlotte's master thesis
anna's dying mother
debra listened and conversed pleasantly
but as the night wore on the exhaustion
began to take a toll on her
the party had been her idea but perhaps
the stress of the trial and the ensuing
media skewering had affected her more
than she thought
she gave an inward sigh of relief when
kevin finally said
let's wrap this up everybody deborah's
about to pass out
god we're so uncouth anna said sitting
here yapping until all hours
she grabbed her purse from under her
chair and stood up rounding the table to
set a hand on debra's shoulder
get some rest honey you've really been
through the wringer
jeremy spoke at last anna's right matter
of fact you should blow off next week
let anna and i handle things just until
the frenzy dies down
debra raised her hand to protest but
kevin headed her off
i'll make her take a break i promise he
said even as debra was shaking her head
good night everybody and don't you dare
offer to stay and help clean up i'll do
that tomorrow
we weren't gonna offer anyway charlotte
said with a wink
the guest dispatched into the night
debra tumbled into bed at just past one
without even brushing her teeth she had
no idea when kevin came to bed
when she awoke six hours later the
sheets were covered in blood
i'm not leaving you alone kevin stood at
the foot of the bed
arms crossed face bathed in morning
light
debra propped herself up on her pillows
wincing at the pain in her abdomen
i'm not an invalid kev you took care of
me all weekend
you've got your classes it's finals week
i'll be fine
he sighed deborah for christ's sake this
isn't a biggest badass competition
you've been crucified by the public
since that damn trial ended and now this
his voice faltered but he recovered
quickly you're staying in that bed
getting some goddamn rest like you
should have been doing before
and i'm staying right here with you
debra recognized the finality in his
tone
normally she would have countered this
with a more commanding finality of her
own and gotten her way
but she was too drained to argue with
him she had to remind herself that he
too was suffering a loss
with a nod she relented the next day
though she put her foot down
it wasn't that she didn't want him
around but she disliked the feeling of
being someone's burden
kevin grudgingly gave in to her on the
condition that she take the entire week
off from the firm
as jeremy had suggested she wasn't happy
about it
but maybe everyone was right and she was
only hurting herself and others by
trying to be superhuman
once kevin had gone to work and the
house was quiet she found herself
thinking of the potential child that had
suddenly vanished on saturday morning
in a torrent of blood and agony the
pregnancy had been
accidental and at first she'd been as
ambivalent about it as she'd been about
kenneth cooper's guilt
but in the three months since she found
out the idea of motherhood had become
more appealing
not least because kevin had started to
change too rediscovering a tenderness
that she hadn't even realized she'd been
missing from him until it returned
it wasn't as though they'd been having
problems before but there had been a
distancing
perhaps inevitable given their demanding
careers and long marriage
the baby she thought could have been
just what they needed to draw them back
together
and now it was gone she pulled the
covers up to her chin and closed her
eyes
it wasn't the end of the world she
thought they could always try again
she surprised herself by smiling and
then drifted off to sleep
an insistent pounding on the front door
awakened her hours later
scowling she turned onto her side but
then noticed that her cell was flashing
from the nightstand
she grabbed it expecting another prank
call but instead there was a text from
jeremy
just me opened the door deborah shrugged
into a robe and picked her way
downstairs
when she opened the door jeremy was
standing there in his trim grey suit
a green wrapped pot of bright yellow
ball-shaped flowers nearly concealing
his face
deborah couldn't help grinning as she
leaned against the door jamb you
shouldn't have
jeremy peaked around the blossoms i
would take credit for these if they
didn't look like something dr seuss
dreamed up
they were delivered to the office this
morning who were they from
debra stood aside so jeremy could bring
the flowers into the house
i'll let you uncover that fun fact he
set the pot down on the dining room
table
she pulled the card free from its
envelope and read the crab scrawl aloud
thank you for everything you did for me
and so sorry for your loss
best kenneth cooper she looked up into
jeremy's face
my loss does he know about the
miscarriage how could he know
it's the internet age miss thorne
everyone knows everything about
everybody
hmm she brushed her hand across the
flowers
sending a fine rain of yellow powder
down onto the table top and the slight
scent of cinnamon and vinegar into her
nostrils
jeremy tilted his head i'm glad you took
some time off
you don't look so great thanks smooth
talker
you know what i mean you needed the rest
he paused staring down at his shoes
and i'm sorry you know about the baby
and about being kind of an [ __ ]
at your party you weren't an [ __ ] and
it's fine
don't get sentimental it gives me hives
he smiled still not looking at her
same old debra finally he met her eyes
i gotta split go back to bed i don't
want to see you at the office until at
least next week
deal you men always conspiring to keep a
lady down
i promise to be scarce good get better
sweetheart
he gave her an awkward hug and showed
himself out
after the sound of his car engine had
faded into the distance
debra poured some coffee and stared at
the cheerful riot of blossoms
she hadn't heard from kenneth cooper
since the trial had ended but he was
still thinking of her it seemed
she pulled her robe tight and tapped her
foot against the floor
not sure if this was a worrying
development or not
had the card simply thanked her she
would have written it off as genuine
appreciation
laced with a little flirtation but the
fact that he'd mentioned her loss was
troubling she was still deep in thought
when kevin came through the front door
startling her she looked at the clock
and realized it was nearly eight
kevin answered her unasked question i
had some catching up to do sorry i'm
late
i stopped and got chinese i figured
you'd be hungry
she was they ate at the table in silence
as the yellow flowers bobbed softly
between them
after a few minutes kevin pointed should
i ask
they're from cooper he plucked the card
from the pot and read it
his brow furrowed he knows our address
they were at the office jeremy brought
them by
he looked at her is this something we
should be concerned about
i don't know yet kevin nodded
do you need me to stay with you while
you're home he paused a beat
never mind i already know he laughed a
little sadly
just thought i'd offer she reached for
his hand
and twisted his fingers in hers i
appreciate it
but let's not freak out just yet okay
just let me know he slipped his hand
from hers and went into the living room
deborah heard the tv come on the next
day deborah was beginning to feel almost
back to normal which meant she also felt
unbearably useless
she woke early shortly after kevin left
and paced around the kitchen and dining
room for an hour
the flower is always skirting the edges
of her vision reminding her of her
enforced quarantine
at last she grabbed the blooms and took
them into the garage where she chucked
them unceremoniously into the trash
then she called anna hoping there would
be some catastrophe at the firm she'd
need to sort out
but anna was unequivocal we don't need
you thorn
stay the hell home finally deborah gave
up and collapsed onto the couch
flipping the tv on even now all the news
networks were still harping about
cooper's exoneration
repeating the lurid details of the crime
again and again
pretty 22 year old victim found in her
car with her head blown off
her body a horror show of bruises and
stab wounds
cooper admitting he'd dated the girl
briefly admitting he'd been enraged when
she dumped him
debra stared at the screen flatly as her
own picture appeared beside those of
cooper and the victim
here is the apex of the sick triangle
the news seemed to whisper
the woman responsible for the monster
going free
debra turned it off and went back to bed
it was dark when she awoke and the house
was completely silent
blearly she reached for her phone 9 30
she scanned her messages all were cranks
she dialed kevin but got his voicemail
where are you
it's late she hung up feeling
disembodied
an hour later kevin had still not
replied
debra threw on some clothes and grabbed
her keys
as she opened the front door something
white caught her eye she turned
pinned there on the door was a baby
booty splashed with red
she slammed the door and locked it she
called kevin again first but he still
wasn't answering
next she dialed jeremy can you come over
here i think something bad is happening
she told the same to anna and both told
her they were on their way over
then she called doug an old friend in
the police department explaining tersely
about the booty
the flowers kevin's uncharacteristic
absence
doug was audibly alarmed and promised to
send an officer right away
after that there was nothing to do but
wait anna arrived first
followed closely by the officer and
jeremy as calmly as she could
debra repeated the events in a voice
that sounded robotic to her ears
spoken aloud the string of incidents
struck her as laughably insignificant
the flowers could have been a simple
well-wishing gesture the booty could
have been one of the innumerable crazies
who had harassed her in the wake of the
trial
kevin's lateness could have a million
explanations
deborah regarded her three-person
audience balefully
sorry to make such a big deal it sounds
paranoid
jeremy began to protest but was silenced
by the simultaneous sounds of deborah's
phone chirping
and the officer's radio erupting in a
burst of static
debra snatched up the phone got a call
said doug body found in a car in a
parking lot of 47th
registered to kevin thorne id on the
body is his too
i'm so sorry she ended the call without
answering
the officer was talking into his radio
occasionally glancing at deborah with an
expression of grim consternation mixed
with pity
deborah's legs threatened to crumble
beneath her but she managed to stay
upright
her vision swam mrs thorne
the officer said the victim was found
shot and stabbed in a manner consistent
with the cooper
murder there's an apb out for cooper now
victim's wallet was untouched but his
keys are missing
do you have somewhere else you can stay
jeremy put his hand on her elbow
she can stay with me for a few days
debra was shaking her head before she'd
even fully processed his words
that's not a good idea jeremy cooper
knows you and anna
if he found me he can find either one of
you i can't put you two at risk
a hotel then i can stay with you anna
said
debra's phone chirped again startling
her so much she nearly dropped it
she looked down at the screen charlotte
she answered and immediately the young
girl's voice was a keening litany in her
ear
deborah have you seen kevin i've been
trying to call him for hours and he's
not answering
and his secretary said she hadn't heard
from him since he left today and i
deborah interrupted gently she told
charlotte everything that had happened
as coherently as she could stealing
herself against the hysteria
that threatened to engulf her there was
a long silence on the other end when she
had finished
so long that deborah thought she'd been
disconnected then she heard a faint
sniffle
but i just saw him deborah in class
today
i'm sorry she wasn't sure why she was
apologizing but there it was
do you need to stay with me charlotte's
voice was barely there
a forlorn ghost cooper wouldn't think to
look for you here
deborah hadn't gotten to know charlotte
as well as she could have over the two
years she'd been kevin's grad
student but the thought of commiserating
with someone who knew a side of kevin
that deborah herself rarely got to see
was strangely appealing i'd like that
deborah went upstairs gathered some
clothes and went back down to the living
room
the officer was posted at the front door
the radio on his shoulder crackling and
squawking
jeremy's and anna's faces were distorted
masks
we'll find cooper mrs thorne said the
officer yes
all right jeremy offered to drive her to
charlotte since she accepted
she hugged anna and allowed the officer
to escort her to jeremy's car
neither of them spoke on the short drive
and deborah was glad
jeremy waited on the curb until
charlotte had opened the door
she waved to him and then ushered
deborah inside
it was a typical student pig sty
littered with dirty laundry and empty
food containers
but debra barely registered the mess
charlotte had clearly been crying
wordlessly she motioned deborah into the
postage stamp kitchen
where she poured them both a glass of
wine they drank in companionable silence
i'm sorry all i've got is the couch
charlotte said between sniffles
once her glass was drained i wanted to
stay up and talk but i think we both
need to sleep
maybe we'll wake up and things will be
okay again
deborah had been keeping tears at bay
until now but charlotte's bare naivete
pushed her over the edge
maybe so she managed to say once she had
settled into the musty smelling sofa
and charlotte had disappeared into her
bedroom and closed the door
deborah found herself drifting off
immediately even though she had slept
for most of the day
she dreamed of her picture on the news
in a lineup that also comprised cooper
and his first victim
there was also a fourth photo of kevin
but half his face was obscured by a
spray of red
she wasn't sure what time it was when
she awoke with a stiff neck in what felt
like a slight hangover
the first thing she became aware of was
a cheery dash of yellow on the cluttered
coffee table
directly in her line of sight she
focused with effort
but for a long time she couldn't make
any sense of what she was seeing
it was a yellow ball shaped flower
confused she tried to struggle into a
sitting position
but her limbs felt ledden she stared at
the flower
comprehension slow in coming and then
notice that beside the flower was a
white baby booty
and propped against that was a printed
photo a blurry image that looked as
though it had been taken with a cheap
cell phone
the flesh tones in the photo soon
separated themselves into two naked
figures
kevin and charlotte there was a sniffle
off to her right
and she whipped her head toward the
sound charlotte was leaning against the
kitchen door
her face red and swollen the pistol in
her hand shook slightly but it was aimed
directly at debra's head
i'm sorry charlotte said her voice thick
she pulled the trigger
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
wow
[Applause]
[Music]
wow
[Music]
call it obsession if you will you
certainly wouldn't be the first
my wife never understood it even up
until the day she left
and i suppose some of my co-workers
twirled their fingers around their ears
behind my back more than once
i know how it sounds you see but it's
been there this obsession
this vast wall before which i am
prostrate insignificant
before college before my myriad failures
before bettina and her bitter farewell
now two weeks old before any of it there
was riemann
are you sure you want to hear all this
alright tape's running is it
okay then well my father was a
mathematician
and a bit of a philosopher he taught at
the college that i attended
and though i shared his compulsive
temperament and his love of numbers
the real meat of math the zany beautiful
out there stuff that was my father's
stock in trade
it just never made much sense to me i
tried god knows but i guess my brain was
just too feeble
when i graduated with a degree in
accounting my father hardly shook my
hand
and went through the whole pride routine
with a jolly my son my son
but i could see his disappointment
plainly there behind his standard issue
horn rimmed glasses
sure accounting is math and math is math
right not to him
sorry i was talking about my obsession
wasn't i god i've gone funny since
bettina left
i suppose that's why i'm here isn't it
anyway my obsession began
and can many of us pinpoint that exact
moment in our lives when all the
whizzing atoms and cast off pieces of
detritus
seem to solidify before us in a single
thunderclap of inspiration
making our eyes pop like expanding
planets and our breath catch in mid
windpipe at the very realization
it was in the summer before my senior
year of high school i was bored one day
as only a reasonably bright teenager
perched on the cusp of adulthood can be
and in my lackadaisical shuffle around
my father's study
that i remember vividly smelled of dust
and tobacco and mothballs as all
father's studies should
i spotted a book that looked interesting
it had some type of constellation on the
front as i recall
i flipped through pages and pages of
esoteric symbols and formulas that i
longed to understand
but it was like looking at something in
a language that is unfamiliar and yet
tauntingly familiar as well
as though the meaning is just there just
one level deeper than you're able to go
and how inadequate i felt standing in a
warm dusty sunbeam in this my father's
sacred place
holding my father's holy book with its
cryptic words that spoke only to him
the last chapter however gave me pause
it was mostly text and as i read it i
felt those spinning atoms converging
into the dawn of my obsession
for the riemann hypothesis said the
magical book with its arcane pattern of
stars on the cover so alchemical
was a mathematical problem long assumed
to be true but never proven
and the subject of much speculation and
calculation
those two words hooked me never proven
and there in that room in my 17 year old
mind that fairly bubbled with hope and
promise and arrogance
was the thought that i could do this
that i could be the one to
solve the mystery and crack the code it
did not matter that as i read the rest
of the chapter of the attempts and
failures of the century's greatest
mathematical minds
i understood nothing of the grandiose
theories all those little pies and
sigmas and crazy exponents upon
exponents
that littered the pages like tiny elven
footprints
it did not matter that i had no more
than a rudimentary grasp of algebra and
trigonometry
i was going to do it i would solve this
thing
and wouldn't my father be astonished
beaming and basking in the light of my
genius
my son has solved the unsolvable
all through college i read everything
within my reach about riemann about carl
gauss
about primes and complex numbers and the
zeta function
i told no one of my work scribbling away
on odd bits of paper every few minutes
of the day
but riemann was always on my lips and in
my thoughts and i was ready to bellow to
the winds of the triumph i was sure was
so close at hand
after all i had the advice of my father
the great mathematician to guide me
graham he said to me once when i was
still quite young
to solve any problem mathematical or
otherwise you must break it down to its
component parts
see it for what it is inside without all
the trappings words to live by
but years passed and the dreams of glory
and delicious payback began to fade
as dreams of youth seemed to do when the
hair around the ears begins to sprout
gray
all seemed lost until i met bettina how
wide-eyed and effervescent she was in
those days
without her childing encouragement i
might have abandoned riemann once and
for all
settling into a mundane existence with
my lovely new wife
the equally lovely children we would
inevitably produce
and the respectable job at the
accounting office dry as noon in the
sahara
but bettina adored me in the beginning
before the fights and the boredom and
the long silences
broken only by the sound of her pitiful
sniffles she adored me
and encouraged me in what i loved she
even feigned interest in my obsession
in the beginning although she told me
much later during a particularly
unpleasant argument
that she never had the slightest clue
what i was talking about and had never
given a [ __ ] anyway
to this day i'm fascinated by the fact
that no matter how well you think you
know a person
when you live together long enough and
begin to peel away their layers so to
speak
break them down to their component parts
as my father would say
you find that they're completely
different than you thought it's most
disconcerting
but i suppose that's why so many
marriages end the way they do
the way mine did anyway where was i
yes so it was riemann and bettina and me
strange bedfellows indeed
i seem to be making progress then during
that first year and the exhilaration of
it was all intertwined with that rush of
love with the shine still on
of nights when bettina and i sat up
until the proverbial wee hours
discussing math and magic in the
universe then making love on the dark
shimmering floorboards of my own study
decidedly less dusty and mothballish
than my father's
that was a good year and i sometimes
weep to remember it
of course it all went wrong as it always
does entropy i think that's called isn't
it
descending towards chaos bettina spent
less and less time
communing with me and riemann in the
study and more time complaining
with puffed and red ring dyes that i was
too often holed up in there with him
mooning among my haphazard calculations
she would come in and stare at me
whining that she wanted me to be the way
i used to be
as if i was the one who had changed she
wanted us to go away together
she wanted a baby before she was too old
so many things
and i would sit there with my books her
words just indecipherable buzzings to me
that's all they were her many laments
because you see i had hit what seemed a
fatal obstacle with raymond
and it was that which occupied my mind
not the heartsick babblings of a
dissatisfied wife
she didn't understand looking back on it
i'll admit that perhaps i was brooding
even unpleasant if only slightly
bettina told me that i'd actually called
out the name riemann during one of our
infrequent sexual encounters
maybe i did i can't really say i was at
the time awash in self-loathing and
failure
and all else in my life seemed like the
static of a far away radio signal
then came the day just two weeks ago
that bettina announced that she was
leaving
when i think about it now i guess i
shouldn't have been surprised but
surprised i was
most drastically anyone would be
wouldn't they more than that though i
felt betrayed
and angered by the fact that she didn't
even have the decency to cry or act
hysterically
as she uttered the fateful words her
voice was just flat
her face blank as though she didn't even
care anymore
and that just the sight of that once
beautiful face that i had long ago
equated with the very visages of angels
hanging there in my study with fish dead
eyes and drooping lips telling me
it's over graham as if she were
discussing nothing more profound than
what she'd had for breakfast that
morning
well i just wouldn't have it she
wouldn't go
it's all a bit blurry from that point
sorry about that
i stood up quickly i remember that the
legs of the chair
giving an anguished screech as they
kissed on the warm floorboards
she didn't flinch or even blink why
should she it was only graham the
mild-mannered accountant wasn't it
and then bits of riemann reams of
illegible scratchings that comprise my
obsession my life's work
were flying see-sawing crazily through
the air catching the shards of summer
sunlight from the window with blade-like
glints of violence
there was a thud and a red rain there
were small rustlings like mice as the
last of the papers flitted to the floor
and in the ensuing stillness oh god a
revelation
i stood before riemann's fortress a dark
and forbidding place of late
and for the first time in months i could
see what might be a way in
a light from heaven itself beaming down
upon the path
the component parts of course just as my
father had always said
you must grasp the problem in both your
hands and hone and refine and divide
again and again boil everything down to
its barest essence
and only there underneath all the
nonsense will you find the kernel of
truth
i went right to work what
oh i'm sorry doctor i seem to have gone
past my scheduled time
i know you're very busy but once i get
started i do apologize
i did want to tell you about the
exciting new turn my research took
but that can wait until next time and by
the way before you go
i'll answer the question that you've no
doubt been pondering all along
did i ever solve the hypothesis after
all that
regrettably no there's been so much
going on this past two weeks as you well
know
but i'm so close doctor so close those
atoms are converging i can feel it
i mean just think of it doc everything
broken down to its very simplest form
peeled to its innermost layer to the
core of its being
can you appreciate the beauty of that is
the number 12 for example just 12
is it a one and a two are three times
four or six plus six
is a human just a body or so much more
the arms the fingers the feet the toes
the veins the bones
the molecules the atoms the heart even
with its beautiful oracles and
ventricles
everything divided once and twice in an
infinity of times dividing without end
i know my experiments with bettina were
interrupted but i won't be stopped
my quest for knowledge is too strong i'm
so close doctor
i will solve it
you